with me
all right so i'll talk about this other
model in which we can try to do
estimation
and
the algorithmic technique here that i'll
introduce will be approximate message
passing and
i'm not going to say too much about how
this generalizes to other models but it
does it says
amp has tremendous power and you'll see
that in two talks we'll see that from
shubert's talk perhaps tomorrow is that
correct and from prager source talk this
afternoon
so
the basic uh vector that we're trying to
estimate is x0 i'm going to call that
the signal so now it's n-dimensional
and let's just suppose that the
coordinates are drawn iid from some
prior
unit variance
now i observed the
following observations following random
variables
zero i x zero j
plus w i j
here i is smaller than j
between 1 and n
w i j is gaussian
so i just showed you so this is a matrix
of course
right
it's symmetric and i only define these
values but these values can be defined
by symmetry i don't care about what
happens on the diagonal that's why i
considered i strictly smaller the j you
can put whatever you want on the
diagonal it doesn't matter
right so this is a matrix model
and okay suppose we want to estimate
zero
so what is one
estimator that you could use
very simple estimator when you estimate
x0 you have a matrix
matrix looks like this
rank one
plus gaussian matrix
all right so we have a rank one
perturbation that will push the
eigenvalues presumably to push the
eigenvalues somewhere push them up
so one thing you can try to do is
compute the first eigenvector and see
whether it aligns with x zero or not
right
so
vector first eigenvector
eigenvalue eigenvector
[Music]
now this is a random matrix theory
problem it's not a very hard one and
then you can analyze exactly uh the
performance of whether okay the
performance of this estimator how much
does it align with the
with x0
so it turns out since i chose my prior
to be mean 0 and variance specifically
the variance variance one the phase
transition happens at lambda equals one
so if lambda
is greater than one then
lambda max of this matrix
will be strictly larger than two it'll
be lambda plus one over lambda
larger than two and two is the relevant
quantity because the um
the spectral norm of this matrix is true
it's a semicircle law right so the
eigenvalues of this matrix look like
this
minus two
if you normalize by square root n
so as soon as
lambda is larger than one you get a
eigenvalue that pops out
so not only that does the eigenvalue of
the first eigenvalue pop out but also
when you look at the first eigenvector
call it v1
you look at how it aligns with x0 and
divided by n so this is the inner
products right
that will converge to a quantity that is
well-known that is like this this much
and this is strictly positive if lambda
is greater than one right you can see
that
on the other hand if lavender is smaller
than one
then the first eigenvalue will stick
will stick to the edge
virtual this is
and
this quantity will converge to zero so
your orthogonal
the first second vector is our falcon
the signal so you cannot do anything
with that
now as we did with maximum likelihood
for the previous problem you can ask
whether this is the best thing we can do
or not
so this question has two aspects to it
can you beat this threshold one can you
estimate below one so that's that's the
first one
and the second question is that even if
you're above one
whatever lambda is whenever you can
estimate can you get the best
overlap
right so this this uh spectral estimator
gives you this overlap
but can you do better is there another
another estimator let's say that works
also only when one does larger than one
that gives you a value that is larger
than this so there are two questions you
can try to answer them both
okay
now let's try to apply what we've seen
um
in a previous lecture so we can write
down what the posterior measure of the
signal given y is so
if you write this down
so we can do the bayes rule right
and that will be let me just write
times exponential
since this is also a gaussian additive
model this is a signal plus noise it's
said that the signal has a more
complicated prior structure right but
that doesn't matter as far as the bayes
rule is concerned
so we get i smaller than j
lambda squared and y i j
it's basically the same expression
right d
p 0 to the power n
of x
and the free energy
and of lambda
is one over n
expectation
[Music]
now you want to understand as we did in
the previous example you want to
understand whether this thing has a
limit or not
um
no it does
and this is a theorem
let me write it so this is called the
replica symmetric formula
it says that for all lambda
positive
fn of lambda will converge point twice
as n goes to infinity to a variational
formula
it's called vrs of lambda
and this is more or less explicit
it's an optimization problem over one
variable
it's a supreme number of all q which are
positive
i have a function c that i'm going to
define
lambda shows up there
minus q squared over 4.
all right
so what is up c
c is the free energy
of the additive gaussian univariates
gaussian additive model
so if i observe as in the previous
lecture
y that is given by this
so this says real
just in one dimension
then phi is the free energy of this
model
r
over 2 x squared dp 0 of x
so you can say perhaps one of one
mystery here that you can ask is why
does the
free energy of the one-dimensional
problem show up in this problem
and here we're looking at a problem that
is presumably more complicated it has
interactions between the coordinates so
x eyes you know
this is a rank one matrix and the
entries of that correct one matrix are
dependent obviously dependent on each
other they're x i x j
but yet you still got something that is
decoupled across coordinates right
so we'll try to answer that and we'll
try to i'll give you some heuristics
about how to compute this and i'll tell
you something about the rigorous proof
so this theorem this has a long history
i don't know who to attribute this to
um
let's say
volvo for the
the non-rigorous
and then we have kawashima that was even
earlier than that
mishimori
even earlier this is like the 80s or
something
rehearsed proof is much uh later so okay
i can attribute it to lulav and yolan
this is maybe 2017
and avedis funding
other people
um
yeah they proved it in various levels of
generality
um
i think this paper gave the cleanest
proof to my
to my taste
and i'll show you i'm not going to show
you really the proofs i'll show you some
heuristics on so the method this is this
target is about the methods and i'll
show you some methods to guess this type
of formulas
okay so this will be a
perhaps an occasion to introduce what is
called the cavity method
i'm not going to spend too much time
because this is a computational method
and i don't want to spend 10 pages doing
computation so i'll just give you the
main ideas
so we have a function that looks like
this um
and you want to compute the limit so i
prior it seems like a very challenging
thing to do
if you push the expectation inside
you're not going to get anything
interesting so the new the anneal free
energy is not giving you the right
answer you cannot just push the
expectation inside
so there is this uh
landmine analysis
this is all about analysis
so this is everybody knows this um if
you have a sequence
of real numbers such that
okay the sequence converges
and the average converges to the same
limits
okay obvious
now we can try to apply this to this
problem so this is your sequence
okay you don't know whether this
converges you would like to to make sure
that this converges but you can write it
as an average
so in particular if
you apply this
you can show that
fn plus one
divided by n let me
do log
of z n plus one expectation
minus log
z n converges to some function fee
then
fn
lambda will converge to that same fee
right
because this is your a n sequence
now if you take this an average
then this is the lemma right
okay so why did i write it like this
now because of the logarithm when you
take the difference you just get z and
plus 1 over z end
and then so here you have a system of n
plus one variables here you have a
system and variables so you're just
taking your system for n variables
you're adding one variable to it and see
what happens
right
so this is where the name cavity comes
from or perhaps it's the reverse
operation you have your system you take
one element out instead of adding it
it's the same thing
and you create a cavity right and then
you look what happens in that cavity and
anything that happens in that counter
will tell you what the limit is
as long as you can make everything works
so this is
okay this is this is
old and um
people have realized this for a long
time since the 70s in physics and
statisticians also have their own
version of this that is called the leave
one out method
it turns out that it's the same thing
perhaps prager is going to talk about
only one else
right
so if you want to do this computation
you're going to have to make some
heuristic assumptions about what's going
on and i'll try to explain what that is
um
what those are
so let's try this
and i want to do this perhaps just
graphically i don't want to write too
many expressions
so here in this model every i talks to
every other j right
the matrix is done so we had a matrix
that was dense
right
so a graphical way to represent this is
just the complete graph on n vertices
now i add a new element to this graph so
i get a k n plus one right and it's
connected to every other guy
here
so this is my vertex n plus one
now if you try to
isolate the behavior isolate the effect
of what this k n has on this new
variable
in hamiltonian try to understand that
that will give you the answer
so if i write h n plus one
so this is my hamiltonian h n is my
hamiltonian so it's whatever appeared in
the
in the exponent here
so if i write x
n plus one what is that
i have
so i have to put an n plus one here
excuse me i have to put an n plus 1 here
well let's just me let me just separate
that as i said i'm going to separate the
effects of kn over the new variables so
i have
the first n
variables that interact among themselves
that i don't care for now
n plus 1 x i squared x j squared right
and now i have the effect of all of
these lines here so this thing accounts
for k n for whatever happens inside
right
now i have the effects of these lines
and i can add them up
so i have i from one to n
lambda over n plus one
i n plus 1
x i
x n plus 1
x i squared
x n plus 1 squared
right
so let me call this this new thing let
me call it little h
so x from one to n i'm going to denote
okay let me change notation so that
everything becomes a bit simpler
so this is x
x n plus one
and x is the n dimensional vector
so this is a function of x and x n plus
one
and now i'm gonna again change notation
xn plus one will be epsilon
okay so the new variable that i'm adding
is epsilon
so you can see that
kn acts on epsilon
in a linear fashion so this is the sum
over 10s you can
do this right
and same thing for this one
so it acts with a field that is random
so
let me expand what y is so y is whatever
the expression is let me expand that
so i have lambda over n plus one
y
i n plus one
x i epsilon
plus lambda over n plus one
x
uh
x zero i
x i
epsilon zero i
epsilon zero
epsilon
minus this term
squares
okay
good
so now if you draw so what happens here
when you look at z n z n plus one over z
n
this is the quantity that you really
want to understand right because that
will give you that value
it's zero so let me write it again so
where should i write it
so y is
y i j is lambda over n
0 i x 0 j so i'm i put 0 when i refer to
the planted signal right
and you have a y here y ihj
and epsilon of course so this is in n
dimensions but if you do the n plus one
dimensional ten you have an n plus one
here
right
and then x sub zero n plus one is
epsilon zero
so this is just an expanded it's really
just an expansion of this just expand
this on your google touch it's really
nothing happening right
this is what you get
what is this this is the integral
of exponential h n plus one h n plus one
is that
so it's just
h n
okay let me
let me remove the plus one here all
right
just for the sake of
illustration this is false but let me
just remove the plus one
now let me remove the plus one
in here as well and here as
well so that's h
x
so i have
this and that
so i just split the prior since it's iid
so this is an n dimensional prior over x
and then the prime of 0 right
but then the n is zn
yeah
ignoring
the n plus 1
in the denominator
you know
these n plus ones
they can have an effect you cannot
ignore them actually
but if you write it like this then you
see what is this this is a gibbs average
of this quantity
right
so if you just split this integral take
this inside
and this is really just gibbs average of
this quantity
right
so this is what i mean by that picture
that i drew you have a system of n
particles that interact between them
using their own laws right
they're drawn from the gibbs measure on
n particles i mean they're n particles
and then they act on the n plus one
variable that i'm going to call epsilon
here through this random field
right they act with an external field
that is linear
so if you can understand the law of this
external field then you can perhaps get
an expression for this
right
so what does this field like it look
like and i wrote it here
i can separate this contribution
from the rest of the contributions so
we're gonna see why
if you have a question please just stop
me
so
h epsilon
i'm gonna write it as
let me ignore the n plus one again
epsilon i'm going to put this guy just
close to it right here
squared and i'm gonna isolate this term
lambda over n ignoring the n plus one
x uh
i
zero i
episode on zero epsion right
okay let's start this for a little bit
this is a gaussian
they're inside the exponential right
this whole thing is a gaussian process
that is indexed by x0 but the x vector x
now if you look at this quantity it's an
average over
this inner product so it's an inner
product between this vector and the
signal right signal vector
and this x is drawn from the gibbs
measure right so draw x
from the gibbs measure right with n
particles and look at the
overlap
divided by n
between that's draw and x zero right
the transit signal
okay so he expects there is
concentration of measure if you expect
that this guy concentrates
i can just take this average and replace
it by a single number
okay let's do that
so the main assumption
called the replica symmetric hypothesis
i'm going to write it a bit more
mathematically than what the physicists
will write but the hypothesis is
there is a queue
such that this thing concentrates around
q
okay so i just put the second moment
there just because i like it i like the
second moment
there exists a q such that this is true
now if that's correct then i can look at
this expression and i can replace q here
right now let's look at the this name
so this is a gaussian process as i said
let's write it as a gaussian process so
this
is a hypothesis
are drawn from the procedure and you
don't know whether that concentrates or
not correct
exactly
so let me write this uh
process let me just write here
this whole thing is
a touch right
so if you so it's a constant process
that is indexed by x and epsilon it's
centered you're taking the expectation
of this thing this thing is zero okay so
this is a gaussian process but when you
add this this is a geometric thing right
so this is uh
you know
i have a gaussian random variable in h
of the expected the exponential of it
if you take the expectation then you get
one
whatever
sigma here you get exponential sigma
squared over two
if you subtract
the pin then the expression of this
thing is one so this is an exponential
margin bill somehow right
so this thing it just normalizes this
this uh this uh this gaussian process so
that when you take the expression of the
exponential of the sentence so right so
let me ignore this part
as long as you can understand the first
term then this thing will just normalize
it
now i said the expectation of this thing
is zero now what is the covariance
structure of that thing
gaussians are only determined by means
and covariances mean zero is the
covariance
one one
two
the sun on to n
and you guys
x i one x i two
epsilon one epsilon two right
that cracks
i just took this thing and i multiply it
by
by itself but for a different test
vector here right that's what the
covariance is so now you still get the
same kind of expression that we got here
right
the gaussian process whose covariance
is has this has this form and you're
asking whether now
does this concentrate or not
and of course this is it doesn't make
sense if you ask that for a for an
arbitrary x1 and x2 but the point is
you're all looking at x1s and x2s that
come from the group starter
if you draw x1 and x2 from the gibbs
measure right
now look at the covariance of this
gaussian process with those tests those
those vectors as test vectors
then this is the covariance and if this
thing concentrates
then i can replace this whole thing by
constant
but i claim that i already made that
assumption
that's this is the same thing as this
because of the nationwide property right
x x 0 is the same thing as x1 x2
we've already made that hypothesis so i
know the distance concentrates
so this whole thing
is about lambda q epsilon one as well
now if you have a gaussian process
that is mean zero and you know the
covariance you can just really just
replace you know the the only thing that
is interesting here is the law of that
process so i can just replace it by
another gaussian random variable that
has the same mean the same covariance
and there's a particularly simple one
this is just
z times square root q that's another
gaussian
that has the same mean and it has the
same covariance
right so if i replace
replace
z
facts epsilon by
square root lambda times q there's a
lambda here right
times z
right
now if you want the expectation of the
exponential of this thing to be one
you're gonna have to subtract lambda q
over two
epsilon squared
right
so that's where this term is gonna
replace this term by this term
now if you do this replacements let me
the q
d times epsilon
if i do that replacement and i put
everything here
but still so now i remove these brackets
because i know that the things inside
concentrate around those cues and then i
can just remove the brackets because
there is nothing around them anymore
i get exponential
what
i said the first term will be replaced
by this minus of course the the right
thing that concentrated so normalizes
z epsilon
lambda over 2 lambda q over 2 epsilon
squared
dp 0 of epsilon
okay now this term
was replaced by
lambda q
epsilon 0
i've seen on
are you assuming anything about you
there exists a queue that satisfies this
q is deterministic
here's a deterministic yes yeah how do
you show i was just curious how do you
show representatives
do you differentiate that quality
or stick to lambda
no no
you have to work hard
that's how you do it like the strength
of the tactical model
especially with spectrum temperature
so what you can try to do there are many
ways of doing it you can do a recursive
thing when you're gonna start peeling
off one by one
is another way to do it where you really
just use the derivative energy you prove
that the hamiltonian concentrates
there's a lot of work i'm not going to
talk about
so let me just continue this and then
perhaps i can come back to your your
question a bit later
um so you see here so what is this this
is really just though if you put a lot
here and you put an expectation outside
that's really just
the free energy of the one-dimensional
model
with a specific cube
so that's how you get the answer
that i erased
but you see there was a lambda q so the
replica formula was
this lambda q minus lambda q squared
over four
i only showed you how to get this term i
did not show you how to get this term
but this term comes exactly from the
from the from the
from the contribution of replacing n by
n plus one
so when you do
the real computation when there's an n
plus one here that then that n plus one
has a non-vanishing contribution that
will give you exactly this q squared
over four
so i have notes on this like it's maybe
two pages of derivation it's not really
complicated
and uh yeah i'll give it to the to the
organizers if they want to share it
but this is really what the the cavity
method is about you just put another
variable
and then see how the system acts on that
variable if you can understand that
action
then you can write down formulas
so how do you prove this this is the
main thing this is this is really how
like the proof works um
you really have to work hard
i don't want to get in there
this is yeah this is uh this is the main
crux of the proof
yeah that's correct same old same same
same exact same thing everything
yeah
yes yeah so because the spike tensor is
the same you know it's also a gaussian
additive model
it's just in a more complicated way
yeah so as long as you're doing uh the
asian inference right so this is a this
is a you know a statistical inference
problem they're all replica symmetric
why either all replica symmetric exactly
because of the nichimori property
so it wasn't replica symmetric i
wouldn't know that these two things with
that x x 0 and x 1 x 2 are the same so
it would have to have two parameters
right q and row whatever so this thing
will concentrate around q
this thing will concentrate around row
so i would have
to prove both you know concentrations
that doesn't hold always as you very
well know right so polar temperature
right
are there other questions about this
perhaps this is like some
impressionistic um derivation of the
cavity method
that's all i can talk about now
um okay so it's already past half the
time and i haven't talked about amps so
let me talk about amt
uh let me just tell you one one way to
another way of doing this it's called
the query interpolation
interpolation this is really a workhorse
in this field interpolation
so you're going to interpolate between
this model this complicated model and a
more simple model and what is the simple
model
is the model where everything is
decoupled as we've seen from here from
this derivation it gives you a hint that
there is a relationship between this
matrix model and the decoupled model
where you have just iid observations
so that's what this does
i'm going to consider a system of two
pieces of observations that are
parametrized by t
this is the first one for t equals one
then this is the original model
and i'm going to look at another piece
of information
which is given by lambda q which is the
q is the same
it's a parameter of the problem and i'll
put a one minus g here
and now i'll just put an x this is a
vector
plus z under some other vector that is a
gaussian so this is an additive gaussian
model where the coordinates are id
id coordinates
all right so observe these two so at
time equals one you get this at times
yeah correct time equals zero this goes
away and you only get the decoupled
version
now this is another so i give you these
two observations and i ask you to
estimate x and you can do the same thing
so you can write down the posterior
measure you can write down the free
energy of this model this is another
statistical inference model right
you can write down the free energy and
that will depend on t
let me call it this
now if you take a derivative of fee
you can try to do the computation that
we did in in the morning or in the first
session
and you get this you get a derivative
that looks like let me go there
you get a derivative that looks like
g
minus 1 4
really whatever you're assuming is going
to show up
plus
this is the derivative
if this goes to zero
then the derivative is constant is equal
to this thing
now phi of one that will imply that phi
of one r s implies
v of 1 is about
the same as phi of 0 plus if you
integrate
q squared over 4 is a
plus this is a minus
right c of zero
is the decoupled model
right you have to decouple the model you
get exactly this expression
now
the q squared over four that showed up
in rs formula really comes up from here
right
but this this doesn't
tell you how to prove that this is zero
so you're gonna have to work
independently to get that to zero
this is just another way of doing it
you're gonna have to prove this
okay let me perhaps stop talking about
the cavity and then do imp
[Music]
so amp is an iteration and it is derived
from belief propagation or message
passing on a sparse graph so this is the
dense version of dots
and these uh iterations are typically
designed to compute means they're
compute they're really
for for doing inference computing
marginals of variables if you have a
complicated system of random variables
like the one where we're seeing here
and i ask you to compute the mean
of those variables the marginals then
you can use amp to do that
and the iteration looks like this so if
you have an input matrix
it doesn't have to be a matrix could be
a tensor but let me just talk about
matrices
it's n times n
the iteration will look like
u l plus 1 l is my iterate count
will be a times m l
minus a constant v l
ml minus one
and what is m
m is a function
of u l
and you can start the iteration for
instance taking u
or m minus 1
to be 0 and m 0 to be whatever you would
like
fixed
and you get to choose the function f at
every iteration you can get to choose
them however you want so this is the
one version of amp there are many
versions of amp more general things that
you can do
so what is b bl is determined it's a
something that the theory tells you
prime
uh few
il
so this is the iteration
so why is this interesting so it's
interesting in many ways
if this matrix is gaussian
and it's normalized by square root n so
that's the operator you know it's order
one the matrix is order one
then the iterates because of this guy
because of this term this is called the
memory term the iterates are gaussian
they're not only gaussian but you can
exactly compute their marginal their
covariance
you can track at every iteration you can
track the covariance of this gaussian
process right and that's very useful and
i'll show you how perhaps if we have
time
so we can do many things with this
one of them as i said is to compute
marginals you can use this for many
other things
so in my particular case for the spikes
vector model we're going to let
a to be the matrix y that we had that's
why
i have to normalize it correctly i'm
going to have to divide it by square
root n
so that the operator norm of this thing
is
just order one
so more particularly more particular
this is what it is the matrix a is that
plus this
and you can do the iteration over this
matrix whatever functions you're trying
whatever you like here
and then you can ask whether you can
estimate the spike using this iteration
right
ffvl is a sequence of functions that you
get to choose the theory doesn't tell
you what they should be
[Music]
so let me show you a theorem that
characterizes uh the behavior of this
iteration
so this is called state evolution
this is the main theorem
that shows up in amp whenever you're
using amp
this is very useful to know
as i said so this theorem characterizes
the exact
distribution of these iterates u and l
and any function of those u's and l's
so let me write it so for any
perhaps i should write assumptions
okay let me just write it here without
assumptions
any pseudo-dipshit functions
which functions
just a version of the theorem
see that it goes from r2 to r
and i'm going to explain what this means
we have
if you look at the empirical
distribution
of the entries
the fee evaluated at uil
and x0 i so this is the spike that
doesn't depend on anything right so this
is just the
but why you you uil is generated from
this iteration right
then this thing will converge as n goes
to infinity to an expectation
of the function
and then instead of having a u here
we have the following we have a mu
l
times x zero plus sigma l
times z and here we have an x0
okay let me tell you what these things
are x0 is drawn now it's univariate it's
drawn from the prior
z is univarious it's drawn from a
gaussian
i have to tell you what these numbers
are these are this is a sequence of
numbers
so what is that sequence of numbers
it's determined by the following
iteration
ul plus 1 equals square roots
lambda
expectation
x zero times f l
of this
small z
and now what is sigma
sigma l plus one squared
is expectation
of f l of the same thing
ul x zero plus sigma l z
squared
okay so this is my iteration
you're gonna have to start it somewhere
this iteration
and that will depend on where you start
your algorithm what this m0 is what's
what's the u0 is
so for instance if you have another and
an initialization that has the following
properties
if
m zero
m zero x zero over n converges if
converges to a parameter tau
and the norm squared of this 10 over n
converges to a parameter rho
then
this iteration will start from mu zero
equals tau
and sigma zero squared equals zero
okay so the pencil the initial
conditions of this dynamical system
will depend on
how you initialize your algorithm
so what does this tell you in perhaps in
in
[Music]
just uh
uh
morally let's say
it tells you that the coordinates forget
about this it tells you that the
coordinates of this iteration
accordingly of your algorithm when you
iterate over the algorithm
the coordinates are
have the same law as this when you draw
the histogram of your vector this is a
vector of n dimensions right it's an
iteration of n dimensions draw the
histogram of that at iteration l
right the histogram will look exactly
like
this law right
it looks like an x zero multiplied by a
constant plus a gaussian multiplied by a
constant that's the histogram
now you do another iteration l plus one
the same thing is true with an l plus
one here and l plus one here so it's an
exact characterization of the behavioral
algorithm at every possible step right
this is like a very strong thing like if
you do gradient descent you have no idea
what the intermediate iterates of
gradient descent do you just know that
it converges if the function is complex
or whatever right
so this is an exact characterization
which is very useful
are there any questions
do you need any conditions on how you
choose okay
uh fl have to be so i didn't talk about
the assumptions
assumptions
fl have to be lift sheets
which is differentiable
and
what is pseudo lift sets pseudo
lipsticks mean
i think this just also needs to be
absolutely rich i'm not exactly sure i
think you can make the theory work
so do lip shots
what is that that's just almost slip
chits
but i allow you more slack
okay so lip chits is this
right with an l and i allow you
a linear growth in the
lipschitz constant
right
so this is for instance satisfied by the
square x squared x squared is not
literally but it is pseudo liquid so i
can put an x squared here and everything
works right
and that's useful you don't just want
which is function you want more general
forms or general class of functions
so that's what i want to talk about now
why is it called approximate message
passage because message passing is uh
well this is just because of the
historical reasons the thing that was
known as message fast and belief
propagation you know you have a
graphical model
and then you just pass messages right so
you have
rights this guy will send a message so
the neighbors of a particular vertex i
will send a message to a vertex
of that vertex i and then something
happens here you have a local
computational rule that combines these
messages and that's sent to this one
right
now if you look at a dense graph
you can still do the same thing
but then you have an n squared number of
errors that you have to track
but it turns out since the graph is
dense
the message that i is gonna send to j is
the same almost the same as the message
that i is gonna send to another neighbor
of it so you can just remove the
dependence on
the receiving end of the message
okay
now if you want to make this work
actually in the iteration i can do this
because i don't have time if you want to
make this work in the iteration you're
going to have to subtract this term this
term has an effects the
when i say that you can ignore the
receiving end you can ignore it's by
making this correction once you make
this correction then everything's fine
and that's why it's called approximate
it's because you're not you're just
sending the same message to everybody
you're not i'm not personalizing my
email to you
particularly i'm just going to say a
mass email to everybody
by using this correction and it will
work it's the same so now the behavior
of the two iterations is the same
that's why it's called approx
yeah so ul ul yeah so there are these
two so it depends on
the particular application of this so
here
uil is some kind of
observation so when you look at ul from
the from the characterization here ul
almost looks like this so it's some kind
of observation that you get an effective
observation of the signal x0 and ml is a
denoised version of it so ml will be the
pin that you're going to estimate with
so in our language from the previous
lecture
ul you can think of it as y
and m you can think of it as the
posterior mean
so this brings me really to the choice
of these functions so how do you choose
this function suppose you want to
estimate you want to estimate optimally
how do you choose the functions to
estimate optimally
right
now suppose you're in the middle of the
iteration suppose that you've picked so
this is a recursive argument suppose
that you've picked fl's up to iteration
10 or something
now i want to care about iteration l
plus 1 and i want to know how to pick fl
at iteration l plus 1.
now i know that state evolution is
correct
right
and at iteration 10 or l whatever
the histogram of the use looks like this
right so you get to observe u this new u
that you computed
and you know that it looks somewhat like
this it has a histogram that looks like
this right
so it's as if you've received a linear
you know observation from a linear
gaussian linear model about the true
signal that you're trying to estimate
with these parameters right with this
with this you know this combination
now if you do that and i ask you if i
give you a linear model and i ask you
how to compute x0 how to estimate x0 we
did this this is exactly what we did in
the first lecture right
so if you receive f l u by l excuse me
that looks like that
sigma l z
observe this
and estimate
zero so what is the best thing you can
do you can do the posterior mean
what is this okay so you do the
computation
whatever it is i have it here
the theory mean is this
mu t over sigma t squared
y l
x minus blah blah
zero dp zero of x over
the same thing
right
now i'm going to pick my functions to be
just that
say take
view
l
to be that
so i reduced the choice of trying to
optimally choose these these functions
into an estimation problem at every
iteration i have an estimation problem i
have a denoising problem to solve
and it's a one-dimensional denoising
problem right
so if i try to just solve the
one-dimensional denoising problem in an
optimal in an optimally diversion way
it's obvious what this choice should be
right
and that's my choice
okay
now if you do this
it turns out now you can prove it it's
very easy
now one can show
that
mu l
equals square root lambda
times sigma l squared
so this
bivariate iteration just collapses to
one iteration under this choice f
so you only have one iteration to care
about because that you have that
relation
okay
now based on this
let me define a reduced parameter
and i'm going to call it ql
and you should i'm calling it ql for a
reason because it's going to relate to
the cues that i was writing for the rs
formula
ql will be one over lambda
okay
now if i look at this iteration and then
i try to convert it to give me an
iteration over ql
i find the following
ql plus one
equals
p prime
of
square root lambda q l
where v prime is the same function that
showed up let me write it again
exponential square root r y x minus r
over two x zero d p zero
so this is the function that showed up
in the
in the rs formula
so you have one parameter to track the
behavior of your algorithm
okay now what do i care about you may
care about many things one thing that i
particularly care about for this
iteration is the overlap between my
estimate and the spike
okay so that's one thing i can care
about
you can show that that converges to q
as n goes to infinity
for all l
right because of state evolution so this
left hand side
looks like
the left-hand side here for a specific
choice of the function c
right if you take c
a few
x zero to be u times x zero
right this is that
right
and now if you compute the right hand
side the right hand side will be indeed
ql and these are simple computations
that you can do
another thing that you can care about
for instance is the norm of this
okay two norm of this that's the same
thing q
okay
[Music]
now i have this convergence
now when you take many iterates
you want to know where this converges
i mean when l goes to infinity right it
suffices to study where this sequence
converges this is univariate sequence
you can try to study it
so it's a fixed point equation right so
just as that's just a fixed point
equation
so how does this fixed point equation
behave
perhaps i'll go over by one minute or
something thank you
so this is q
this is the 45 degree line
and
i'm going to plot 2 times c prime
so the function i'm going to plot is 2
times c prime of square root lambda
q
all right
so when i choose the prior to be mean
zero turns out that this function starts
here
now what matters here is the derivative
of the function at zero
if you compute the derivative of that
function at zero so let me call this
v of q maybe
turns out that as i said this is zero if
the prior is centered
the derivative happens to be lambda
lambda times the variance of the prior
if the variance of the prior is one this
is just land though so depending on
whether lambda is greater than one or
smaller than one the tin will
go either up
from the from the 45 degree line or
below it right
so if lambda smaller than one
the thin will do something like this
if lambda is larger than one
then we'll do something like this
okay lambda smaller than one lambda
larger than one
so here you see that the only fixed
point is zero in which case you're going
to converge to zero this iteration will
converge to zero and you're completely
orthogonal to the signal
now if lambda is larger than one
there are two fixed points there is this
one and this one
so happens that this is the optimal
thing that you can do this is the
division you know if you do posterior
mean you're going to get this value of
overlap
now if you do a amp so you're going to
have to track this fixed point iteration
start anywhere you'd like let's start
here you can even start here if you're
more careful
okay let's start here
see where i go right so we converge to
that point it's just a fixed point
iteration
okay
that's nice
so for functions for for if the
functions if i didn't lie to you when
the shape of the function is exactly
this then this is what happens
and you see that the behavior of the
algorithm is more or less the same as
behavior of the spectral method as long
as as far as these the the the
critical threshold is concerned it's
always one
so but there are situations where
the critical threshold is below one in
which case my function will look like
this so it'll still start from zero
and it will instead of being concave
like this it'll do this
this is for a low lambda
now if you start increasing london
grease lambda a bit more
you have two intersections
i don't want this
oh
the point is lambda is strictly smaller
than one
here right lambda is still strictly
smaller than one because this is what
the curve looks like the derivative here
is lambda and if the the derivative of
the curve is below that means that
lambda is smaller than one right
still you still have two intersections
turns out that this one is unstable this
one is stable this is q star
this is what the optimal biasing method
will give you if you were to able to
compute the posterior mean of the of the
measure of the that builds them and
measure you we will get an overlap that
is here this is the overlap this is the
optimal thing right
but now try to apply amp to this so
forget about these two curves let me
remove them for clarity
okay i don't know how clear that is but
okay let's see
so if i start here let me start here
so i go here
i'm gonna have to go left
this is the stable fixed point so i go
to zero
i don't go here i go here
right
so your algorithm is still drawn to the
non-informative fixed points
this is why i call non-informative
because it's octal gives you a state
that is orthogonal to the true signal
right even though the optimal thing
tells you that you have to be here
right
so this is a computational phase
transition always happens that lambda
equals one regardless of what the
optimal division information
theoretically optimal thin is to do
so for this set of problems
the problem seems to be hard
algorithmically i don't know how to
solve it it's information theoretically
possible i have an algorithm to solve it
amp doesn't solve it and yeah
we don't know of any algorithm that can
solve it an example of such a problem
okay i have to wrap up an example of
such a problem is sparse pca where the
problem where the prior
is a three delta prior so when you have
mass rho over two over minus 1
let's say minus 1 over square root rho
plus some mass over 0
plus mass
over plus 1 over square root rho i'm
dividing here by square root row so that
the prior is still unit variance it is
mean zero but for rho small enough which
means that you're putting enough mass on
on the on zero then the curves will
indeed look like this
right
so this is a discontinuous phase
transition
face transition
why is it discontinuous phase transition
as you're changing lambda
so recall
that movie that i showed you the few
frames of the movie that i showed you
about increasing lambda and how the the
the curve looks like
it starts like this like this and it
starts increasing but it has a bump here
so at some point the bump is going to
touch this line and you're going to have
a critical point that's going to show up
that critical point showed out of
nowhere right
because before that the only critical
point was 0 and you suddenly jumped from
0 to something that is strictly positive
so if you draw
q star
if you draw q star as a function of
lambda
this is lambda this is q star
f lambda
0 0 0 up to this value that is critical
and then you go here
and it starts increasing
right
this phase transition is continuous
because the
if you try to do the same
movie again
the
this picture will look like this up to
lambda c which happens to be one in this
case and it'll do this
so we see that the order parameter this
is called the order parameter
it is it has a kink but it's continuous
across that transition
here it is discontinued it has a
discontinuous jump
so this is a marker of computational
hardness
okay discontinuous phase transitions are
bad as far as algorithms are
concerned because now if you do amp
i told you it only works up to when
lambda is greater than one so you're
gonna have to wait up to lambda one
so a and p will be like this
and once you get to lambda equals one
then you jump and you follow the optimal
curve
here
okay in this problem inp will just
follow this curve always okay so there
is no composition rms here there's a
computational hardness here
okay figuring out whether phase
transitions are continuous or
discontinuous is an old problem
and okay so the fields metal is alerted
because of figuring out that certain
phase transitions are continuous and
certain others are discontinuous but not
for these type of models for the ease in
modeling finite dimension so let me stop
there and then i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
that you'd like to ask or vote on
questions that other people love but
science
slido.com
the code is
one